ohne diese raupen wäre ein skibetrieb in
unserer zeit nicht mehr denkbar mit über
500 ps ziehen sie in der dunkelheit ihre
runden
sie sind die formel 1 auf eis
während wir schlafen sitzen die fahrer
bis in die frühen morgenstunden in ihrem
cockpit und kreieren die perfekte piste
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit über 50 jahren sind diese maschinen
die basis für einen sicheren und
konstanten skisport
und hier im schwäbischen laupheim werden
sie entwickelt konstruiert und in einer
großen montagehalle gebaut
die montage ist derart komplex und
diffizil dass kein roboter zum einsatz
kommt und alles von hand verbaut wird
hier arbeiten ausschließlich top profis
sowie fertigungsleiter martin scharf
ersten bullis sind high tech fahrzeuge
vergleichbar mit einem supersportwagen
nur eben für den einsatzbereich im
skigebiet zur ausstellung von perfekten
bedingungen für skifahrer
[Musik]
die montagelinien sind in
unterschiedliche touch stationen
aufgeteilt die dann in einem bestimmten
zeitfenster ihre teile am fahrzeug
anbringen wie hier die räder am
fahrgestell
[Musik]
insgesamt sechs stück werden binnen
minuten verbaut
die mitarbeiter sind wie ein
eingespieltes orchester das nie aus dem
takt kommt und am ende eine wunderbare
symphonie auf ketten entsteht
[Musik]
nach der montage der achsen im hauptraum
war nun die laufräder montiert diese
dienen hauptsächlich zur führung der
laufkarte und sogar verteilung auf den
boden hauptsächlich wo das fahrzeug über
die planetengetriebe hier hinten
angetrieben über einen hypothetischen
antrieb bei uns so fahrzeug zutraulich
betrieben wird hier befinden sich dann
auch die bremsen bzw die hand nehmen das
fahrzeug ist die ebenfalls die drohne
ist eingeschaltet am nächsten
montageplatz findet die hochzeit statt
und das riesige kraftwerk wird in
fahrgestell verankert über
520 diesel-ps werden das gefährt
antreiben aber es ist möglich dass man
hier in laupheim in zukunft auch elektro
motoren verbaut kaum vorstellbar aber
die zukunft hat bereits begonnen
in der schwäbischen alb und auf anderen
arealen werden bereits die ersten
elektrisch betriebenen pistenraupen
getestet die maschinen sollen vor allem
im nordischen skisport zum einsatz
kommen und die ökobilanz bei langlauf
und biathlon verbessern test ingenieur
andreas meyer und sein team wollen das
perfekte pendelt zwischen energieaufwand
und effizienz finden
ob pkw oder nutzfahrzeugen die größte
herausforderung bleibt die batterie und
die fällt bei einem gefährt dieser größe
und leistung auch enorm aus
so und hier sind unsere batterie packs
mit ihr mit einer partie spannung von
400 volt die werden jeweils oben
zusammengeschaltet und hier haben wir
noch das herzstück auch noch das ist der
hoch wohl verteiler hier wird es
zusammen geschaltet und jeweils an
unsere radantrieb links und rechts und
auch ein die elektrische fräsen die
elektromotoren die spannung werde
bereitet
nicht nur der kettenantrieb zapft
reichlich energie auch die kälte diese
maschinen kommen in erster linie bei
minusgraden zum einsatz und das ist
bekanntlich der größte feind jeder
batterie
[Musik]
dennoch reicht die power für rund
zweieinhalb stunden
während eine
batteriekapazität von 100 226
kilowattstunden
das sorgt für eine reichweite von 2 bis
2 5 stunden je nachdem was man an
leistung benötigt an der fräse oder auch
in dierath antriebe die antriebe haben
eine
leistung von 60 kw 92 kw peak und auch
die fräse ist elektrisch angetrieben
noch setzt die ökologische raupe vor
allem perfekte spuren für langläufer und
biathleten doch dabei soll es nicht
bleiben auch wenn vor den entwicklern
noch viele hohe hürden stehen
[Musik]
weitere herausforderungen und sicher
noch sein wie
temperaturen über wissen jahr sind
solche partien so hochvolt batterien
eine herausforderung für die kälte und
das sind jetzt genau die dinge wo wir
hier oben auch in mehrstetten erhoben
[Musik]
diese erprobungen werden noch einige
zeit in anspruch nehmen um technische
wie auch logistische herausforderungen
zu überwinden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zurück in die werkshalle am motorblock
werden weitere module wie die
auspuffanlage verbaut
dabei kommt die bauanleitung ganz
digital per tablet an den jeweiligen
montageplatz
mit unserem neu eingeführten montage
informationssystemen worden allen
mitarbeitern alle informationen
bereitgestellt die ja zum einbau der
komponenten im fahrzeug benötigt zum
beispiel das abgas und wo
beziehungsweise der entscheidung für
micro unter katalysator genau so wie man
es sich in der 3d animation sieht
die pistenraupe soll am ende aber nicht
nur technisch sondern auch optisch
überzeugen und dafür sorgen michael kuhn
und sein entwicklungsteam
es soll zum einen kraft vermitteln und
aber auch solidität das heißt wir haben
hier von raum spare er einen
angedeuteten überrollbügel am fahrerhaus
und ein leicht aus sonnengereiften
design das soll zusätzlich kraft
symbolisieren und wir achten auch darauf
dass bei fahrzeug von der 1 generation
zum nächsten kässbohrer typische
formensprache beibehalten wird das und
jederzeit erkennen kann es ist ein
pistenbully aber den neuen pistenbully
über monate tüfteln die designer am
neuen look zunächst per zeichnung und
dann in der animation am pc die
fahrerkabine soll einerseits kraft
ausstrahlen zum anderen am ende wirklich
kräftig sein
steht das konstrukt kommen diese männer
zum einsatz nicht der schweißroboter
sondern zwei scharfe augen ruhige hände
und reichlich erfahrung sorgen dafür
dass die pistenbully fahrer in ihren
cockpits sicher sind
produktionsleiter uwe thierer kann sich
auf seine vollprofis verlassen hier
sitzt garantiert jeder schweiß punkt auf
den millimeter genau
die warenhausgruppe für unsere
pistenbully fahrzeuge zwei sind wir im
eigenen welt mit eigenem personal
man will nichts dem zufall überlassen
und beim thema sicherheit sorgfalt und
qualität auch absolut keine kompromisse
eingehen
zusammengeführt und anschließend in eine
vorrichtung
zusammengeschweißt
im einsatz wird die kabine später durch
extreme berg- und talfahrten enormen
kräften ausgesetzt seien dieser
verantwortung sind sich die schweizer
bewusst
ist der letzte schweiß punkt gesetzt
wird des kabinen gerüst in die
lackierkabine geschoben
auch hier erfolgt kein standardverfahren
ganz im gegenteil
[Musik]
unsere fahrer häuser werden in einem
zwei schicht komponenten aufbau auf 143
mio lackiert es ist besonders wichtig
bei unseren fahrzeugen dass der lack
aufbau bis zu minus 40 grad kälte
resistent ist damit der lack nicht
platzt und die aufgeklebten
kunststoffteile auf der beschichtung
entsprechend lange behalten
jetzt kommt erstmals ein roboter zum
einsatz der jede ecke jeden winkel und
jede kreuzung am kabinen gerüst
fehlerfrei in mehreren schichten
besprüht
[Musik]
ein spezielles computerprogramm steuert
nicht nur die motorik sondern justiert
auch die lack zugabe
nachdem rahmen wird dann auch die
verkleidung in knalligen rot lackiert
hierdurch bekommt die raupe zum einen
ein stylisches outfit zum anderen ist
sie auch bei nebel und schneefall
bereits aus der ferne leicht zu erkennen
zurück im werk wo die mitarbeiter
bereits die ersten vorbereitungen für
die verkleidung der fahrerkabine treffen
auch an dieser station kommt hightech
zum einsatz
nachdem dem fahrerhaus gerippe
geschweißt kontrolliert und lackiert
wurden anschließend werden die
glasfaserverstärkten kunststoff teile
auf die klebe flächen aufgebracht das
ist der boden des fahrerhauses wo später
der fahrersitz und dies des cockpits
darauf installiert werden
sitzt die bodenwanne werden mit einem
spezial industriekleber weitere teile
angeklickt
durch die ständige vibration sowie der
einwirkung von zu kräften an der kabine
würde sich eine reine verschraubung über
die jahre locker der hocheffiziente
kleber dagegen absolviert die
kraftentfaltung und hält die
konstruktion auch unter starken
belastungen zusammenhängt
an ausgewählten punkten wird der kleber
noch von schrauben unterstützt
dieses verfahren wird im vorfeld in der
entwicklungsabteilung überprüft
[Musik]
doch das team ist neben der außenhaut
auch für die hochtechnologie im inneren
verantwortlich wie bei der gestaltung
und bedienbarkeit des andreus in dessen
mittelpunkt der multifunktionale
fahrersitz steht bei der fahrer steht im
mittelpunkt und deswegen muss auch der
sitz
ökonomisch und b cool aussehen
wir sehen hier an dem sitz vielfach
verstellbare möglichkeiten das beginnt
natürlich von der linie von der
belüftung wir haben hier eine
federung am fahrzeug dass mir die harten
stöße und vibrationen die von laufwerken
haben ja ein kettenfahrzeug kommen die
zunächst sozi fahrer auslagerung gedämmt
werden und hier nochmals durch dieses
schwimmen gestellt am sitz komplett
eliminiert werden so dass der fahrer
wirklich sehr komfortabel seine acht
stunden hier fahren kann weil das ist
das a und o man fahrzeuge bevor so ein
neuer sitz auf den markt kommt wird die
durch die fahrer in feldtests getestet
es gibt schon gefahren es gibt etwas
kräftigere fahrer vor allem muss dieser
sitz passen und die entsprechende
einstellmöglichkeiten bieten bei allem
komfort muss er sitzt auch ein gutes
feedback für die piste vermitteln dass
von dem hier ein genaues austarieren
zwischen komfort und dem promoter des
fahrers
neben der funktionalität achten die
entwickler auch auf die ergonomie und
das erscheinungsbild im cockpit man baut
die formel 1 auf eis entsprechend
gestalten sich auch lenkrad sowie der
joystick
[Musik]
das lenkrad findet gerade seinen platz
in der fahrerkabine die mitarbeiter sind
absolut eingespielt ist der raum noch so
klein sie finden jeden anschluss
um millimeter geht es auch beim einbau
der mittelkonsole unter der viele
elektrische assistenzsysteme wie die
steuerung der zahlreichen scheinwerfer
verbaut sind die besonderheit beim
baseball ist im gegensatz zum normalen
pkw dass wir nicht nur ein völlig durch
und abblendlicht haben sondern
zusätzlich sind noch arbeitsscheinwerfer
für den fällt bereich als auch deren vom
feld bereich vorhanden es ist glaube das
fahrzeug wird zu 80 prozent bei nacht
betrieben und gute sehen ist
entscheidend dafür dass der fahrer auch
wirklich ein top arbeit abliefern kann
so ist hat sich aber noch ein spezielles
für mich nämlich hier einen zuschauer
auf oben am dach mit dem man dann noch
spezielle spots spezielle
ausleuchten und heiraten kann
nicht nur im pkw bau wird die elektrik
immer komplexer umso wichtiger ist auch
der check vor der auslieferung zu beginn
waren es front und rückschein werfer
heute werden hoch intelligente systeme
integriert von denen nicht nur der
fahrer sondern auch die bergbahnen
profitieren die skipiste wird gescannt
einsatz systems nur satt nennt sich das
mit dem kann die schnee tiefe unterhalb
dem fahrzeug gemessen werden die idee
dahinter ist dass man nur so viel schnee
wie nötig tatsächlich produziert schnee
ist natürlich teuer vor allem maschinen
schnee und die weniger schnee produziert
werden muss desto vorteilhafter
fdp 23
und die nächste generation wird bereits
auf der zugspitze getestet
auf deutschlands höchstem berg befindet
sich auch deutschlands einziges
gletscherskigebiet das jetzt zum
testgelände wird
das besondere am zugspitzplatt ist dass
die männer nicht nur fahrer sondern auch
mechaniker ihre raupen sind und daher
das testteam qualifiziert bereichern
einer von ihnen ist tobi aderhold er
weiß dass auch sein skigebiet von der
neuen hightech in form eines
intelligenten auges profitieren wird
[Musik]
bei uns ist das problem dass wir hier
oben keine schneekanonen haben dafür ist
halt der schnee extrem wichtig und wir
können da keine schneeflocke sag ich mal
verschenken wir brauchen jeden schnee
fleck ist es bei uns eben sehr mit dem
schnee
und das alte system hatte ist alterslos
als system hat nur eine momentaufnahme
das heißt ich muss über den schnee
drüberfahren dass ich unter mir sehe wie
viel schnee unter mir ist
und das heißt ich muss diese ganze
fläche erst abfahren dass ich sehe wo
ich was wegschieben kann und wo nicht
bei der nächsten generation die wir
jetzt gerade auch testen
und ist es eben so dass ich 30 bis 50
meter vorausschauend schon sehen kann wo
schnee liegt oder wo schnee fehlt das
heißt ich kann expliziter reagieren kann
den schnee von links nach rechts oder
auch gleich in meiner sprung mitnehmen
wenn ich sehe im 50 meter voraus fehlt
der schnee und hier kann ich was
mitnehmen dann kann sich direkt neben
mit vor und das ist eben sehr effizient
bei uns weil wir dadurch
kein schnee verschenken und genau wissen
wo schnee liegt und den eben gezielte
einsetzen können
[Musik]
die ressource schnee wird gerade im
klimawandel zum kostbaren gut
für die sinnvolle effiziente und
ökologische verteilung auf den pisten
wird ein enormer technischer aufwand
betrieben der bereits im sommer beginnt
das system ist natürlich mit einem
riesenaufwand verbunden das heißt im
sommer wird hier unser gebiet unser
skigebiet komplett mit einer drohne
vermessen das heißt die fliegen das
komplette gebiet ab schauen wo wollten
sehen wo steine sehen wo schotter ist wo
vielleicht auf fels kanten sind weil
eben im winter des komplett verschwindet
das wird eine ebene wir sind somit nicht
mehr wo jetzt die muldensteiner oder
sonst irgendwas herget
der erste schritt zum autonomen fahren
im skigebiet das intelligente auge
blickt praktisch durch schnee und eis
hindurch dies ist gerade im hochalpinen
bereich von großer bedeutung da sich das
gesamtbild durch schneeverwehungen über
nacht ändern kann
[Musik]
war eigentlich hilfe ist da oben des
mossad leaders sensor der sendet 300.000
lichtpunkte pro sekunde aus die
reflektiert werden und so erkennen da 30
bis 50 meter vor dem fahrzeug schon wie
viel schnee wo liegt das system kann man
sich ähnlich vorstellen wie bei den
autos das acc dieser abstandshalter
system funktioniert mit infrarot
und so sehen wir genau wo und wie der
schnee liegt
jetzt muss ich dabei auch weiter bis zum
reparieren das nicht von allein
die neue technologie erleichtert nicht
nur die präparierung der pisten sondern
gewährt den fahrern auch mehr sicherheit
und vermeidet kollisionen mit einem fels
wir fahren hier nicht ob sanften wiesn
sondern auf gletscher eis und geröll
letztlich aber ist der fahrer
verantwortlich
sein know-how und seine erfahrung sind
bei jeder fahrt gefordert aber wie fährt
es sich eigentlich mit 500 ps unter dem
sitz
ganz einfach zum fahren fahren kann
jeder sag ich immer aber eine piste
präpariert wir haben nur ein pedal es
ist unser gas wenn ich da runter geht
dann steht der uli das ist praktisch so
eine automatische bremse gehe ich und
bremst da einfach da haben ein ganz
normales lenkrad wie fast wie beim auto
auch nun das ist nicht runde damit gebe
ich die linke richtung vor und dann habe
ich jemand joystick damit steuerschild
da kann ich alle funktionen am schild
abrufen mit verschiedenen
tastenkombinationen
genauso wie die fräse hinten also die
ganze steuerung von dem pistenbully was
zur piste gehört läuft wie wir den
joystick ich bin auch die ganze zeit am
regeln weil es eben nicht sein kann dass
ich die hand einer davon nimmt sondern
ich muss wirklich die ganze zeit
arbeiten einen flug im blick haben die
fräse im blick haben und wenn ich im
steilen hang mit der winde da muss ich
das halt auch noch in bekam also es ist
nicht so dass man da einfach mal noch am
handy sein kann oder seine zigarette
rauchen kann
und dass die raupe bärenkräfte hat sieht
man hier mühelos schiebt sie tonnen von
schnee über den hang die kunst besteht
aber darin mit dieser enormen an
schubkraft dennoch gefühlvoll umzugehen
tobi macht dieser job sichtlich spaß mit
der arbeit im skigebiet hat er seine
passion gefunden auch wenn er manchmal
etwas über das ziel hinausschießt
im werk bereitet man sich nun auf die
zweite hochzeit vor die fahrerkabine
wird mit dem unterbau vermählt auch bei
dieser traum muss man umsichtig vorgehen
und ein hervorragendes augenmaß
mitbringen
es geht nicht nur darum eine haube auf
ein gefährt aufzusetzen
vielmehr müssen auch zahlreiche
kreisläufe sei es elektrisch oder
hydraulisch geschlossen werden
[Musik]
beim aufbruch des fahrerhauses auf dem
fahrzeug müssen die zylinder eingehängt
werden um später das fahrerhaus einfach
kippen zu können um eventuelle wartungs
und instandhaltungsarbeiten durchführen
zu können somit ist gewährleistet dass
waren zu jedem zeitpunkt auch immer wir
vom fahrzeug dann kommt
es hat wunderbar geklappt der test
verläuft problemlos
man hat fast das gefühl die kabine
verneigt sich vor den technikern
jetzt muss natürlich in einem weiteren
verfahren gecheckt werden ob alle
systeme funktionieren dafür hebt sich
dieses tor und gewährt einblick auf den
prüfstand der pistenbully wird zum leben
erweckt ja nun sind wir in der
inbetriebnahme angekommen alle
komponenten sind soweit angeschlossen
und das fahrzeug kann jetzt mit
betriebsstoffen öl kühlwasser und
kraftstoff befüllt werden und dann kommt
der große spannende augenblick der zwölf
liter hubraum 520 ps motor kann das
erste mal gestartet werden ok
auch der techniker freut sich wenn sein
baby das erste mal brücke
war beim ski fahrer haben mich die rote
fahrzeuge den runden tischen wurde ist
er fasziniert und daheim haben wir auch
ein skilift und auch zwei fischen
polisina darf ich die heimat fahren und
dann habe ich 2017 die entscheidungen
treffe für verkehrsbüro anfang an habe
sie haben eine ausbildung als
trainingsmaterial gemacht und seit
letzten sommer
arbeite ich hier jetzt in der
inbetriebnahme
und das erfüllt ihn bis heute mit stolz
unter seiner regie setzten sich die
systeme in bewegung diese hydraulik
steuert später einmal die fräse am ende
der raupe
jede bewegung wird von einem joystick in
der mittelkonsole gesteuert
jetzt sehen sie hier
das ist es läuft werden sie nicht die
frisch gespurte linie
hier kann ich dann direkt wieder hohe
klasse
und dass mich sehr für das war die
wohnung leuchten
aber das allerwichtigste am pistenbully
ist gewiss die kette die man hier im
ausgerollten zustand sehen kann neben
dem kabinen rahmen wird auch sie im werk
gefertigt um das bestmögliche resultat
zu erhalten
lediglich die rohen werkstücke werden in
die montagehalle geliefert
das hier ist das ausgangsprodukt für
unseren prozess ist ein aluminiumstangen
press profil
das hier in dieser anlage gearbeitet
wird es gibt verschiedene ausführungen
vom aluminiumprofil breite schmale hohe
je nach einsatzgebiet und anforderungen
des fahrzeugs
zunächst werden die metallteile mit
einer cnc anlage auf maß zugeschnitten
auf den kettensteg wird dann im
anschluss eine schiene aufgebracht die
zum einen den steg schützt aber auch für
den nötigen griff im gelände sorgt
[Musik]
doch dem nicht genug damit die raupe
auch bei starken steigungen und
vereistem untergrund nicht ins rutschen
kommt werden mit einem industrieroboter
noch metalldornen angebracht ähnlich wie
spikes beim laufschuhe
[Musik]
obwohl auch aluminium verarbeitet wurde
wiegt diese steg mehrere kilo
so wir haben hier einen kettensteg einen
aluminium und stahl kettensteg so
genannte kombi kettensteg der wurde hier
in dieser anlage vorbereitet und zwar
mit einem spiegel und einem einfach der
ice greifer dient zur steigfähigkeit im
gelände und auch diese stahl leiste mit
dem abgesenkten bereich hier dient dazu
einfach um das fahrzeug perfekt im bauch
zu bringen der jetztige kettensteg wird
in der anlage jetzt zusammengebaut
diese matten werden speziell für die
ketten montage gefertigt und halten
selbst hohen kräften stand
zudem müssen diese gummimatten auch
besonders kälteresistent sein und auch
der ständige nässe sowie
temperaturwechseln widerstehen können
die ausgerollten gummibänder werden hier
jetzt in der weiteren folge gestanzt und
mit aluminium buchsen versehen
die ketten müssen über jahre im
täglichen einsatz halten und sind der
garant für eine sichere fortbewegung im
skigebiet
sind die löcher im millimetergenauen
abstand gestanzt werden die stege
mitunter legt platten in einer
spezialmaschine verbaut
[Musik]
auch hier greift man auf hochwertigste
material bei werkstoffen und bauteilen
zurück
[Musik]
aus diesem behälter mit werden diese
unterlagen automatisiert nach vorne
bewegt wie es handelt sich um eine
aluminium unterlage und eine stahl
unterlage diese werden dann automatisch
zugeführt über ein transportsystem oder
in der kettensteg mit den gummibändern
verschraubt wird
sind alle stege verschraubt wird die
kette aufgerollt
jedoch wird sie nicht im werk sondern
erst am jeweiligen einsatzort wie hier
in kitzbühel aufgezogen jetzt endlich
kann der gigant seine 520 ps auf die
kette bringen
betriebsleiter stefan hessenauer
arbeitet jeden tag und bei jedem wetter
mit dem pistenraupen
er bringt sie manchmal auch an ihre
grenzen und kennt dabei jedes kleinste
detail
ja wir sind doch jetzt beim seitenflügel
der seitenflügel hat die aufgabe um den
schnee von der seite herein zu befördern
und den praktisch auf die andere seite
und einer anderen ort zu transportieren
dann können wir dort zum
heben senken und zum neigen das ist
eigentlich die größte herausforderung
vom pistenbully weil das immer abhängig
ist von den schneeverhältnissen bei
harten schnee reagierte schild am boden
ganz anders als wir bei schnee und das
ist immerhin wieder der winkel vom
schild steht das ist eben diese neigen
bewegung und wenn man zu weit ist dann
so genannt fritz die in den boden ein
und wenn man so weit hinten ist hat man
gar kein schnee mit und die
herausforderungen
der sich die männer jeden tag stellen
einen pistenbully fahren kann fast jeder
eine piste präparieren nur die profis
jeden tag ändert sich die
schneebeschaffenheit oder durch
verwehungen auch die höhe
unter weichem sulzschnee können sie
plötzlich auf harzer eisschichten
auffahren
den piloten in der formel 1 auf eis wird
bei ihren einsätzen alles abverlangt
[Musik]
der schwierige wo es ebenso handeln in
szenen sind dann relativ aggressiv je
nach abhängigkeit der schneeverhältnisse
wins out ist ganz anders dass wir uns
was ist und das ist die tendenz geht
dass die die schilder in den boden eine
will wenn man dem entsprechenden
eigenbewegung macht oder eben nicht in
den boden wenn man den eigen weiterhin
pflegen
die piloten müssen für die perfekte
piste das zusammenspiel zwischen schild
freise und kette gekonnt arrangieren
alle module werden im cockpit mit einer
hand von joystick gesteuert
neben hightech wie dem scan ist das
richtige fahrgefühl mit entscheidend
auch für die beständigkeit der abfahrten
und dieses gefühl wird in erster linie
über die kette zum fahrer übermittelt
[Musik]
was haben jetzt bei der kette angelangt
also die dritte ist ganz wichtiges
bauteil zum pistenbully insofern weil
das natürlich im prinzip die
lebensversicherung der pistenraupe ist
ohne kette ist nichts mehr es gibt
verschiedenste varianten von ketten was
man darum sieht ist eine stahl leiste
die stadt leiste ist ganz wichtig für
erstens verschleiß zweitens seitliches
abrutschen auch mit diesen spikes die
sind auch für steigfähigkeit und
seitliches abrutschen steigfähigkeit
zuständig
doch kette ist nicht gleich kette je
nach modell typ aber auch topographie
steilheit der hänge und pisten profi
werden von den betreibern
unterschiedliche ketten aufgezogen
eine komfortable fortbewegung muss
genauso gewährleistet sein wie die
überwindung von steilhängen
mit der heutigen technik oder mit 518
wir diese pisten maschine jetzt hat kann
man einfach mit der fünf bank hätte die
kraft dementsprechend immer so gut
übertragen und ist dann hat man doch als
export oder schon sieben bank hätten
weil einfach die kraft sie dann auf mehr
bender aufteilt und diese dann einfach
auf der laufleistung positiv auswirkt
wie beim auto reifen je breiter desto
komfortabler liegt er auf der straße
darum jetzt die verschiedenen staaten
das heißt verschiedene steht und
beantworten wie man zuerst stück sagt
komm zwischen 56 und ziehen band gibt es
auch verschiedene steg höhen also die
stehhöhe ist höher der stehe hieß je
mehr steigfähigkeit hätte
weiter dass sie den abstand zwischen den
stegen mache ja bist du die
steigfähigkeit hingegen wirkt sie das
dann nicht unbedingt positiv für die
laufruhe aus das ist letztlich die höhe
je mehr steak das man hätte umso besser
ist es bei weichen verhältnissen in sulz
schnee vor allem im frühjahr wirkt sich
natürlich bei
dementsprechend anderen
schneeverhältnissen wenn es nur die
hälfte in den boden eingeht negativ aus
weil dies dann größere brocken vom boden
herausnimmt und die fräse natürlich mal
wieder wesentlich schwerer blutungen
ganz schöne beste zu machen
auch die reichen über die sich die kette
spannt sorgen zusätzlich für laufruhe
und ein sicheres fahrverhalten
also diese laufräder sind nur führungs
räder um die kette in den in den spur
bügeln zu führen aber antreibt wird nur
hinten dieses zahnrad im prinzip dies
greift zwischen die spuren klein und
belegt somit so die kette
damit die skifahrer am nächsten tag
wieder über eine perfekt präparierte
pisten ihre schwünge ziehen können
wie ein feiner weißer teppich zieht sich
das skigebiet über die hütte ohne den
einsatz der raupen würden sich die
abfahrten in nur wenigen stunden in eine
buckelpiste verwandeln
[Musik]
die raupe muss mit den
unterschiedlichsten neigungen im gelände
zurecht kommen und dabei noch freise und
schild richtig koordinieren diese
verschiedenen fahrmodi werden an diesem
test stand durchgeführt hier finden
motor getriebe und fahrwerk ihren
rhythmus und ein klang
der computer errechnet hierzu ein
spezielles programm
[Musik]
über mehrere stunden zieht sich der
testverlauf bis jede situation
durchgespielt ist
[Musik]
jedes fahrzeug ist wären dort
produzieren wird nach der inbetriebnahme
auf den prüfstand gestellt dort werden
die leistungsmerkmale
quasi real einer loipen oder
pistenpräparierung abgefragt wie man
hier an diesem bildschirm sieht werden
zum beispiel kühlwasser temperaturen
hydrauliköl temperaturen oder andere
druck parameter kontinuierlich überwacht
und aufgezeichnet um für einen späteren
fall davon sie wahr zu sein oder dass
wir verschiedene fahrzeuge miteinander
vergleichen können hat das fahrzeug den
testlauf positiv absolviert erfolgt die
modifizierung je nach modell und
ausstattung wird zum beispiel noch eine
seilwinde auf die raupe aufgesetzt
jetzt befinden wir uns in der
poleposition bei der formel 1 auf eis
wir werden unsere seilwinden vormontiert
unsere seilwinden haben eine zugkraft
von 4,6 tonnen und einer länge von 1400
metern
hier haben wir eine 40 gewinde diese
wird jetzt auf das fahrzeug montiert
insgesamt kommt das gefährt jetzt auf 13
tonnen
wie will muss bei der montage millimeter
genau ausgerichtet worden die schrauben
sind ins sicherheitsrelevantes bauteil
und müssen 100 prozent sitzen sowie auch
mit dem entsprechenden drehmoment
angezogen bauen
die seilwinde kommt in erster linie bei
steilhängen oder sehr vereisten hängen
zum einsatz und darf nur von besonders
erfahrenen piloten gesteuert werden
kein wunder hängen jetzt fast 13 tonnen
am seil und jeder kann sich vorstellen
welche kräfte an der verankerung wie
auch an der winde wirken
der fahrer muss ständig die zugkraft am
seil überprüfen damit seine wie auch die
sicherheit des gerätes gewährleistet ist
nebenbei muss er auch noch schild und
fräse bedienen
[Musik]
ja da haben jetzt diese winde die winde
ist ein herzstück der besten maschine
wir haben da
1400 meter seil darauf die seil wert an
den anderer beginn der piste einen
ankerpunkt befestigt und dann dass sich
das seil auf komfort mehr drehen dann
ist es ja fix ankerpunkt der was
wirklich fix sein muss und dann ist
diese winde eigentlich im gegensatz wie
viele glauben keine winde wo jetzt wenn
die pisten maschine steht einfach die
maschine hochziehen kann sondern das ist
eine unterstützung sondern und eine
hilfs finde und die hilfs wende hat
zugkraft von maximal 4,6 tonnen
und unterstützt einfach die maschine im
steilen gelände dass man einfach am
besten die pistenqualität zusammenbringt
und den schnee bsv nach b transportieren
die seilwinde dient nicht nur dazu die
raupe beim aufstieg zu unterstützen
sondern auch von einer seitenlage oder
schräglage abzuhalten der neigungswinkel
mancher steilhänge ist jedoch derart
steigen dass selbst die seilwinde an
ihre grenzen kommt hinzu kommt dass die
pisten unter der schnee auflage vereist
sind dies dienst war zur stabilisierung
der piste birgt aber auch gefahren für
die pistenbully fahrer
und genau mit diesen gefahren werden die
männer bei der gefährlichsten und
bekanntesten rennstrecke der welt
konfrontiert
wenn jetzt noch die rennstrecke herren
in die mausefalle ist extrem steil aber
es ist ganz ei ne gerade besteht das
heißt es ist vom reparieren herr nicht
so schlimm obwohl sie extrem steil ist
für schlimmer sendern diese alte
schneise weil ist schräges und ganz
schräge pisten sind da ganz schwierig zu
präparieren ebenso ist diese haus
bekannte quellwasser berechtigt ist auch
ganz schwierig zu präparieren weil sie
einfach extrem schräge ist mit so dass
der ganze junger vorkommen werden die
streifen reparieren darf sondern die
sind wirklich die erfahrensten leute was
die genre jahrzehntelang machen weil
einfach die unfallgefahr oder das risiko
dass irgendwas passiert dann zu hoch
wäre wenn wir jetzt bedenken wir
präparieren die komplette streit zu 100%
meter bisschen maschine jeder ankerpunkt
ist doch geprüft mit wirklich durch
zertifiziert und da ist es wirklich ganz
ganz schlimm wenn bei seiner reißen
würde weil einfach das gelände so
grenzwertig ist dass wir mit unfällen
sie einfach ein riesen problem hat
[Musik]
die streif nichts für schwache nerven
sie fordert die skirennfahrer ebenso wie
die männer im cockpit
[Musik]
bei der streif als rennstrecke herrschen
natürlich andere anforderungen als auf
einer roten oder blauen piste hier
schalten die fahrer vom sport auf den
komfort modus und dabei kommen der fräse
und dem sogenannten finisher eine
besondere bedeutung zu
mit ihnen wird skifahren zum
butterweichen genuss
das soll sie mal als bei der quelle das
heißt die fresswelle hat zwei hälften
eine linke und eine rechte hälfte
mit verschiedenen szenen themen
bestimmungen das heißt jemand wie die
fresswelle bestückt ist dementsprechend
wer schnell verarbeitet weil natürlich
die abhängige ist wo ich die skigebiete
wie hoch wie tief geht es nach unten wie
wir haben wir viel kunstschnee haben nur
durch eine und versorgung
voraussetzungen
am ende führt der weg zur perfekten ski
piste immer über das richtige
zusammenspiel von physikalischen
gesetzen das beginnt bei der produktion
von technischen schnee mit hilfe der
schneekanonen und endet beim profil auf
der schneeoberfläche
[Musik]
hier sieht man jetzt die chemische
struktur also mit hochtief hochtief das
heißt man erzeugt mehr oberfläche
und es ist positiv dass gefrier
verhalten setzt die struktur der
finisher die hoffentlich der skifahrer
in der früh in der gleichen
gleichmäßigkeit und und schönheit
vorfindet das betrifft natürlich nur die
frühaufsteher weil wenn man einige
skifahrer von sind und ist die situation
so
mit den kranken der heutigen show
neben der technik spielen die
koordination und organisation eine
wichtige rolle dabei sind alle
pistenbullys im einsatz miteinander
vernetzt und kommunizieren auch
untereinander
wenn ich brauchen wir den basisstationen
die ist da oben stationiert und an
sämtlichen stationen und herum
funkstationen das war es was die daten
von dem neuesten maschinen im prinzip
holen und dann haben die anderen wissen
müssen entweder weitergeben wir haben
bei allen besten maschinen zeit links
seitlich aus dass alle taten was andere
für die maschine aufnimmt auch aktuell
in my life is too much better der spur
gespielt werden das war auch noch selber
alles zu befahren sind kriegt immer die
aktuellsten daten oder anderen pisten
auf meinem bildschirm und somit immer
aktuell
durch den täglichen einsatz sowie die
festgelegten routen und pisten wissen
die fahrer immer tagesaktuell wo sich
wie viel schnee befindet und können
ihnen an die richtigen stellen verteilen
früher war es ein blindflug oder eine
fahrt nach gefühl und erfahrung
[Musik]
heute kann man mit dieser technik auch
wesentlich ökologischer und im
umkehrschluss auch ökonomischer mit der
ressource schmiel umgehen
wir haben jetzt die schnelle lösung das
heißt jetzt aktuell haben wir unter der
besten maschine
119 m das heißt 119 cm schnee
der bildschirm ist schnell am bildschirm
farblich dargestellt das heißt die sehr
genau wo meine bis maschine steht ich
konnte so auf summen größer machen
kleider machen hier noch wie es brauch
ist jetzt dass wir da am 19 unter mir
hat sich das aber cm davor zwischen 50
und 75 cm sehen und somit war sie
eigentlich im vorhinein zwar hat da kann
ja was nicht hingeben dass sie dann
gleichmäßig schneehöhen haben wir werden
ein herz beginnen schauen immer dass wir
an den steilen pisten vor allem oben
sehr viel schnee hand und unten ganz
ganz wenig schnee weil der skifahrer
wenn der dann zur see fahren beginnt
durch die schwinge den schnee und
natürlich tausende skifahrer den schnee
automatisch nach unten bringen und wenn
jetzt über theoretisch die gleiche
machen würde dann habe ich noch zwei
drei wochen unten führt zwischen e und
oben sind zu wenig schnell ich denke es
ist einfach das richtige im herbst schon
mit dem hintergedanken so zu arbeiten
dass sie war als oben braucht sehr viel
schnee und unten reicht man aber schnell
nur um die maschine relativ vernünftig
beenden zu können
mit dem 600 polaroid aktuell die
weltweit modernste pistenraupe über die
skigebiete dieser welt aber die nächste
generation entsteht bereits auf den
rechnern jede generation ist ein unter
zeichen gesetzt
so auch vor über 50 jahren
1969 wollte das erste modell über die
berge schlichtweg weil sich sein
erfinder karl kässbohrer als
leidenschaftlicher skifahrer über die
qualität der pisten geärgert hat damit
seinen skiurlaub nicht im fiasko und
ärger endet entwickelte er ein gefährt
das das gelände zunächst wie eine
planierraupe platt walzen sollte
heute profitieren alle skifahrer von
dieser erfindung auch andere hersteller
in europa folgten dieser idee und
schließlich wurde auch eine
meisterschaft unter den schnee- und
pistenraupen veranstaltet
in unterschiedlichen wettbewerben wurde
am ende der meister gekrönt
über die jahre wurde dann der einsatz
vom alpinen auch auf den nordischen
bereich erweitert
[Musik]
wer weiß wo wir heute wären hätten karl
kässbohrer schien nicht an einem buckel
verkantet damals wie heute sind die
maschinen knallrot und werden vor jeder
auslieferung noch einmal auf hochglanz
poliert er ist der ferrari in der formel
1 auf eis das soll man sehen aber auch
spüren und pistenbully ist ein sehr
emotionales produkt gelegen bereits bei
der entwicklung einen sehr großen wert
auf schönes design und gute konturen so
dass das fahrzeug zum beispiel wie diese
pistenbully 600 polar auf dem eis und
auf dem schnee eine gute figur macht wir
befinden uns hier in der champions
league und freuen uns schon auf den
einsatz dieses fahrzeugs im schnee
es ist soweit ein neues ketten fahrzeug
ist für den weltweiten einsatz startklar
im außenbereich wird das tonnenschwere
gefährt verladen und in den skizirkus
transportiert
ein pistenbully ist mehr als eine
schneehaube dieses fahrzeug vermittelt
kraft hightech energie design und wenn
man auf seinen spuren fährt auch eleganz
[Musik]
jetzt versteht man warum viele einmal im
leben nicht nur banker sondern vor allem
auch mal pistenbully fahren wollen
[Musik]
zwischen max power and creation